my name's cassidy uh i uh if you ever
want to look up my newsletter i have a
tech newsletter that uh i share every
uh every week at cassadoo.com and then
slash newsletter and then i've also got
a few other goodies on there
um and i work at nullify and netlify is
a place where you can
host websites and and do a lot of cool
stuff it makes your uh
your build processes a lot easier for
building cool websites
um but we're not here to talk about me
or netlify today we're here to talk
about react
um so uh this is going to be kind of an
introduction where
if you've used react before this first
part might seem a little bit slow but i
think it's important to kind of get the
same vocabulary going for everybody
um just initially and then we can get
into what react hooks are and everything
um so whether you're a beginner or
you've done it for a while it's good to
think of react like this
um react itself is a blueprint
um and then react dom uses that
blueprint to build user interfaces
um and so react dom is the target
platform it's targeting the document
object model in the browser
um and similarly if i had react
native and then i'd change this to react
native and
set up some other things i would still
be using react but react native would be
using that blue blue blueprint
that react has made to make user
interfaces for
uh for mobile so that's the difference
between the two if you're ever
confused about that so if i want to
make a react element and then render it
to the dom so that way i can
show it on the side over here what i'll
do is i'll do
const react element is equal to
i don't know a div hello
[Music]
and then i can do a const
what const dom element
and then in here i'm just going to get
an element from this page and so in my
html right now i have a div id root
also if you need me to zoom in on any
fonts let me know i tried to do my mess
with my monitor here but just let me
know
um with this div id root here i'll do
document
dot get element by id
and then root not woot root
and so we've got a react element we've
got a dom element and now we want to put
them together
and so we put them together with react
dom and so we'll do
react dom dot render and that's going to
put
the react element
and the dom element together and so
if i were to refresh the page hey we've
got hello
oh i'm zooming in on the wrong thing
hello
and so we've got we've got something on
the page um and that's
that's how react works you take anything
that you put
in this react element into that dom
element and
it lives inside of a div and that's
that's how react runs and what's really
cool about that
is because it just lives inside of a
single div you can kind of make
really large applications just in one uh
small
html thing and and now react has been
around for a while
so this doesn't seem particularly novel
but i've been doing web dev for a long
time
and when this first existed it was
mind-blowing because it meant that you
could put all of these giant
applications
into a single div if you wanted to
slowly convert from
backbone to react you could kind of have
react to live
in different parts of uh your backbone
components until you could
uh convert everything to it so i just
think that this is a cool thing that
your hello world with react
is just these three lines of code i
think that's great um
but that being said there's html in here
oh no uh we're kind of used to it now
in the web development world especially
with vue.js and a bunch of other
frameworks out there and
and libraries that let you do this but
uh what this is this is jsx
and it's not just putting html in in
your javascript as much as it seems like
it it's actually
uh it's javascript that
transpiles to uh or it's html
syntaxy that transpiles to regular
javascript so what it's actually doing
under the hood i'm actually going to
comment this out
and i'm going to make a different react
element const react
element and what i'm going to do is i'm
going to say react.create
element and it's going to be a div tag
it's not going to have any attributes or
anything so i'll put null
and then i'm going to write hello
like that and now it's
printing out this exact same thing and
let me scoot my window a little wider
from
line length here so as you can see it's
i mean yes it's different because i
didn't capitalize it or anything
but uh this this line right here this
react.create element
is the exact same thing as doing uh this
div
hello on the inside and so uh that's
this is what's happening under the hood
that jsx is converting
to this react.create and um because it's
javascript you can get as abstract as
you want
we have this hello thing here but what i
could do is i could put this in a
variable and do like
let text equals hello and then
take this out and put text here
and then it'll render the exact same
thing i could turn this into something
really funky where i make it
an immediately invoked function where
inside of here we return
text text where we return hello and then
it'll do the exact same thing but then i
could do
text plus and then a bunch of
exclamation points like this
it'll add the exclamation points there
and it can get really abstract and you
can actually add
as many children as you want here um hi
there let's just say as an example and
it just appends it
and so because this is how a
react-a-create element works
uh these are just different children
inside of react-create
and so this is a text node this is a
text node
um this also means i could also do
react.createelement
inside of here and then proceed to make
giant
react applications all just using this
kind of syntax
that is totally allowed but that gets
pretty gross
where instead of doing all of this giant
react.create element thing that
that repeats over and over again you can
just do something nice and simple like
what we had before
with this uh react element with the div
hello
and then instead of typing that hello in
there we can take in
the text variable like that and so
whenever you want to have
a return to javascript and put whatever
expressions you want
you put it inside these curly braces
right here um i hope everyone's
following again let me know if you're
not
and say so in the chat but this is
this is how react works at a very very
basic level um that being said
we want to start getting into hooks and
we want to start making something that's
a little bit more interesting so i want
to
go through one more vocabulary thing
before we actually move into
making these hooks so we have this div
here
and it's just an element that we've put
inside of here and and we could even do
something
like we put a div inside of here and put
that react element
inside of the div that is totally
allowed um
and now it's saying the text react
element i've got to do the
braces like i mentioned before um
but what if we want to make a reusable
component
right now again this is
react.createelement
it's not creating a component it's just
creating an element
this is just the return value of that
react.createelement
if we want to turn this into a component
instead of an element
a reusable component it's done
this is how you do it you just make it
into a function so instead of doing the
return value
of react.real element you do a function
that returns it and so i could for
example turn this into a button
and then i'll turn this into a button
here
or not a button there a lowercase button
button and then button and then uh
i will instead of having this expression
here i'll do
button like this now it's a button
and not only that because it's a
reusable component now
i can have as many buttons as i want
look at that they're all saying hello
and they're buttons that can do
things um and there there's a lot of
stuff that you can do with this now that
you
have an actual button made and so let's
just say you don't want to
always have it say hello you want it to
say other things
i could have text equals something and
i'll say
uh hello and there that doesn't change
anything here we need to take in the
variable
inside of this function and so i'm going
to have the variable
text right there and now uh
our other several buttons don't have
text passed in this one is no longer in
use and so i'm just going to comment it
out
but now we can add a bunch of different
text and so we can make something that
seems a little bit more
real by doing add and then
subtract for example then i'll take out
these buttons there's so many buttons on
this screen
so now we've got add and subtract we've
got buttons that don't do things but
they could
and so now we've got something that uh
it's starting to
get a little bit more real when you pass
variables into a component this is
called props they're
they're properties of a component it's
kind of like saying attributes
um if you wanted to say uh for example
if you had an html attribute of like
class or id or something it's just like
that but in react we call them props
um and they don't have to be just
straight values you you
don't have to do add you don't have to
do subtract you don't have to just do
a number you can have a function passed
in too and so for example if i wanted to
have
on click um i could have a function
passed in where
on click i want it to console.log
something i'll do
console.log um
we added hooray that was not creative
but
it's okay it's the afternoon um so if i
have this on click here
i can click this button and nothing will
happen because i didn't actually
use this prop so i'm going to put on
click
inside of here and then i'm going to do
button on
click and then i'm going to do on click
and i should decrease my line length i
don't know how to do that quickly i'm
going to change that in
settings really quick because we're
about to have some very long lines
so sorry line
length please be in there line length
yes okay i'm gonna do 50 and that should
that should be better
or not whatever it's fine i'll just do
you know what i'll do i'll do this
also i'm sorry if you hear very loud
noises outside my window it just started
raining really hard
and i live in seattle so i guess that's
to be expected
okay but anyway we have this button
it's on click and text and so with this
on click right here now when i click
this button
it says we added right in there look at
that it's so
cute um it doesn't actually do anything
except log stuff
but it's cool and you don't have to name
it
just uh on click uh you could do
just like i don't know fish and then i
could call that
fish and then in the on click in here
it'll be named fish
and that will totally be allowed and
it'll work and when i click on this
it'll still print that we added because
we're still applying the on click
to the button itself but we're passing
it in from the parent
now this might seem like a very very
simple oh option c changes it it changes
the wrapping
i'll do that nope that does not it gives
me one of those
i'm just gonna not do that um
but anyway or option z
well that doesn't do it okay that's fine
thank you for trying
in the chat um so anyway
we have these events that are happening
and they seem like very basic ones but
let's just say we had some component
like
some very important
form like this and we had an on success
in here and there's some function
that that is called in there um
that means when this on success is
called someone filled out some very
important form
registration something else what have
you they hit the submit button
it's sent the form was processed you got
a successful response back
and now this on success function gets to
be called
that's that's a very big deal and that's
really a
a big part of the heart and soul of
react being able to pass things via
props
and compose these components that uh
really can do a lot of cool stuff with
that and so
anyway that is props now
we don't have something that is very
real right now but this is where i'm
going to start getting into react hooks
now um if you've used react before last
year
then you probably have done a lot of
class-based components
where instead of having a component that
looks like this you might have had
like class button extends
react.component and then you have a
constructor and all kinds of life cycle
methods in there
that still is fine but i'm here to tell
you
stop stop because
uh these those kinds of class-based
components yes they work
but uh there's a lot of things that are
happening
as react is being developed that just
won't be supporting class-based
components anymore
um there's the only case for using
class-based components now
is error boundaries but uh that is
something that
is going to be fixed soon i actually
have talked with the react product team
about this
and it's going to be just in functional
components so you're only going to
be using function components from now on
that is my pitch
let's actually use some hooks though now
so that way i can show you
the power of these hooks um class-based
components have the attribute about
state right
how does hooks replace that good
question let's do that right now
so i'm going to import use state
all hooks are are javascript just like
jsx is javascript
all of these hooks are javascript i
actually think a more fun name for hooks
would be like
uses because they all just start with
the word use
but whatever anyway let's just say that
we have
um i hate to do something so boring but
let's just say we have
a counter component we have function
counter
and in this counter component we're
going to have some buttons
and so i'm going to return a counter
i'm going to do a div in here and i'm
going to have
another button and then another button
like that um
so that'll work um
button and then button i'm gonna do that
and i actually have some words to say
but i'll just
get this part done first okay so if
that's the case i'm gonna take out
these and i'm just going to put a
counter
in here like that so we have a counter
these buttons don't have any text in
them um what i'm going to do
instead of adding the text as
uh as this sort of this sort of prop
what i'm going to do is i'm going to add
the text in here and i'll say add
and then i'll say subtract so
so far nothing has changed that's
because i have to actually use them
when you pass things in like this as
children of the component
that's actually a special prop called
children
and so if i were to do children like
that
then oh fish is not defined that's okay
i'll do fish is going to be
uh something and i'll i'll pass them in
like this
fish fish is officially going to be our
on click
get it officially ahaha okay
anyway so we're going to uh be passing
this in
must be a sign an expression i know
let's just i'm just going to do
an empty function right in here so it
stops yelling at me
um and you can see that i am a flawless
coder
okay cool nice all right
we're back that pun was not planned this
is just
my life okay so we have add and subtract
they don't do anything but now they're
taking in children so we can put
whatever we want in there
so technically i could do a button
inside of a button
buttonception like that and now look at
that there's a button inside of the big
button
you should not do that but you can and
that's what javascript is all about
okay so let's just say that we want to
use this use state hook we want to make
this
a state driven component what we can do
is we can create a state variable and so
normally let's just say we have like
let count equals zero
and we want to display the current count
and so i'm going to have a div and the
i'll say
current count is this variable count
when i do that nothing will happen and
also even if i did do
like some function add let's just say
i'll do
a const add is a function
that will increase the count and i'll do
like count plus one or count
plus plus whatever um that's all well
and good but because this isn't a state
variable
it's not going to do anything it doesn't
actually
tell react hey you need to re-render the
component
because uh the state has changed so to
convert this into a state variable
what i'll do is i'll do use state
right here and then i'll turn this into
a tuple if you've done some computer
science that's a
word you might not have heard in a while
and we have count
and set count and so
with you state the parameter passed in
here is the initial state of that
variable
count is the state variable and then set
count is the
thing that changes that state variable
and so with this add function let's just
say
also i didn't actually put it in here
but pretend i
did and you were totally sold by my
sales pitch there about why that was
wrong um
i'll make a subtract function don't yell
at me
ah okay subtract okay
so if we want to actually make this real
what we can do is i can do set
count of count plus one
inside of here i'll do set count
of count minus one like this
and now when i click these buttons oh my
gosh would you look at that
it's beautiful it's a counter it works
and so
it's setting the count and then it's
increasing it and decreasing it
and uh what if more than one function
could manipulate count where would that
be or is that not really allowed
oh that's totally allowed and i will
talk about that um that's a i'll
list that in there but yes that's that's
totally allowed to have multiple things
uh manipulate count um so
we we have the we have these buttons
working now it's manipulating the count
variable
and it's really cool because in in react
um which my whole thing is giant now
what's cool about it is how specific it
is
where as i'm increasing and decreasing
it doesn't re-render the entire page it
doesn't do a repaint of the whole dom
if you'll notice google does this little
shiny purple thing right there
it's just changing the thing that
changes in the dom
and that's what's really exciting this
little tiny text node is the only thing
that's changing
and so as a result when you have
something that's
causing really large pieces of state to
change
let's just say it's not just a single
variable but let's just say you want to
determine if someone has logged in and
you want like certain
things to re-render because someone has
logged in so they should see their
profile
it won't re-render the entire page it'll
just re-render the parts of the page
that matters
and that's really good for performance
and that
there's so many implications with this
this is this is what's really cool
now one thing i want to point out with
state
the state and props i think are the
really core aspects of react to
understand
to to get going you can build a lot of
applications with just these
that being said with class based convert
components versus functional components
state is treated differently and um i
kind of want to
implement it but i'll do this i'll i'll
do this if we have time because it's
that's something that
we could get very deep into and we don't
want to get deep into that but
with function components what happens is
let's just say
like i am react i'm going to say i am
react
in a comment here i am react now
if i were react what i do uh when i
create some kind of uh some kind of
thing and you're asking about is this
operation async like set state
let me explain because not really um
so if i am react um what happens when
i'm
initialized or whatever there's some
kind of dom table
um and the dom table is is a thing where
the components will live
and then whenever i create an element i
can do like let
element equal button let's just say i'm
going to
create a button and it's going to have a
state of
whatever or i guess a counter would be a
better example since we're doing counter
but anyway
where we have our initial state is zero
and then what happens is a react will
commit that to the dom
so commit that element to the dom this
isn't real
react stop pretending it is vs code
helping me out
oh so it commits the element to that dom
table
now when it commits that element to the
dom table then
it says old element is now equal to
element
and now whenever whenever counter
changes whenever the state changes
it does a diff where it says now element
is equal to
counter again but the state is now equal
to one
let's just say and it does a diff
between
element and old element
element like that and then it only
commits
that diff to the dom these functions are
not real but this is how it works
so when it commits only that dish to the
dom it doesn't commit
the entire counter thing it only commits
the change that happens
this is very similar to git diff for
example
whenever you run git diff you know how
it has like the plus and minus showing
the exact line that changes
it doesn't commit the entire file
to uh to the current change that you're
making it only commits the
changes that happens and that keeps it
very efficient and that's exactly what's
happening here
and so with functional components what
happens is it just
recalls the counter function and so
it'll do
counter and then counter and then
counter every single time you state
the state uh change is called it just it
just
changes the state that way when we had
class based components when you had
class counter extendsreact.component and
everything
your state values that object of the
counter was something that persisted
over time
so whenever you did set state
and then stop that whenever you did set
state and then
whatever object that you wanted to pass
in to change the state
it was changing the state on a specific
object
so it was an async thing where if you
tried to use state immediately
after you had to do it inside the
callback function but with functional
components
because it's a complete re-render of the
component that's not how it works
because when set count is called
it re-renders the entire component to
the page
so it's not the kind of thing where i
would do set count
and then call some function in here
to happen right when the state changes
um you don't need to do that anymore you
can just call that function
in your component because the state is
already different
when this component is run i hope that
makes sense
let me know if it doesn't um but it does
it let's see it re-renders the entire
functional component every time it's
called
yes it re-renders it but again the only
changes that are made to the dom
are uh the variables that have changed
but yes it
recalls the entire function again okay
people say gotcha i love it great thank
you so much because that helps me if i
need to re-explain things
um i am going to comment this out
but if you have questions on it let me
know um
so anyway this is state this is this is
generally how it works
you can change state um on all sorts of
things
typically what i do is just primitives
in here
uh like strings or ins or something or
booleans
um you can do an object where if i
if i were to have like fish's cake and
then
and have a bunch of different values in
here and then
counter is whatever
yes you can do that but because when it
does this diff right here when it when
it does this diff between the element
the old element and the new element it
does a triple equals diff
um which react in javascript javascript
is fun
so this is true
but this is false
and i'm not sure if you know why but in
case in case you don't know this
this is just comparing objects or
whatever but
this triple equals is saying this object
and this brand new object are completely
different
objects in space they're not comparing
the values of the object they're
comparing the whole things
and so that means you could get
unnecessary re-renders
if you have an object inside of you
state if you want to
have giant state objects like that
instead of having
just another state variable like error
set error like this i'll do use
state is false like that you can have as
many of these as you want
but if you don't like that uh i
recommend using reducers which
i don't know if we'll get time to talk
about reducers but
i've given talks on reducers before and
if you look up
cassidy williams reducers on youtube you
will find it
um is the hook system the diffs and
stuff still using the react dom system
yes
it is we're still rendering this counter
with react
dom right down here um so
that's that's how that works go for
reducers in a nutshell
i'll try to i'll try to squeeze that in
we'll see um
so anyway that's that's how these work
now
i want to talk about some other hooks
now uh
one hook that i think is particularly
cool is
the use effect hook and this one i'm
going to do a bit of reworking so
right now we have just like this counter
right here
which is cool we like it you could even
change it so that way like instead of
buttons you have an input element that
changes the state and that's totally
allowed
um but i was thinking we should try to
call an api together
and i found the pokey api the pokemon
api
and it seems pretty fun and so i figured
let's let's call it
that being said we have this we have
this counter here
uh i like it but i'm going to uh
make a new component just kind of on top
of it i'm gonna call it
pokemon um and i'll put a function all
the way at the top here and we'll just
make a new
pokemon function function pokemon
and then i'm going to return
a div that says hello pokemon
like that and now we've got hello
pokemon on top
of our counter here so uh
first we want to we want to make a
pokemon we want it to render some kind
of pokemon's name
so i'm going to make a new state
variable and i'm going to
say pokemon and then set
pokemon and i'll do use state
i'll do no i could do pikachu first
just to keep it simple and then what
we'll do is we'll do
pikachu oh not pikachu pokemon in here
so now it's saying hello pikachu that's
pretty fun
cute right uh is there a reason to use
function instead of const
no it's purely because my brain works in
fun ways um
but yes a functional component can be an
arrow function
i could do const pokemon
is equal to this whole thing that's
totally allowed
i just didn't feel like it but yes you
can do that
uh this it's purely personal preference
um
uh yay oh i'm glad that's helpful um
yeah so it's it's just a different way
of
writing functions um so what i want to
do
is i want to not just say hello pokemon
but i want to get a user input
to to be able to tell me which pokemon
i'm saying hello to
so i'm going to scoot this down and
instead of doing just this hello pokemon
i'm going to add an input element and so
i'll do
an input on change inside of here
and then i'm going to do capture the
event
and then in here i'm going to do event
and then
set pokemon to
event.target.value
value and then let's see
i want to make sure oh i didn't close
this that's why it's freaking out on me
okay we have this ch on change and then
i want to have the
that value to be an input value
i'll just say pokemon
to start and then oh and type equals
text
text we don't want any tests here okay
cool
so it says hello pikachu if i say
hello ditto
look at that as i type it changes that's
so fun
okay but we want we want to get real
data not just
not just whatever we type here um oh
someone wants me to do jigglypuff yeah
jigglypuff that's a thing um but
we what i want to do is i want to not
just get
whatever is in this input i want to take
what's in the input and call an api
the pokey api and then based on that i
want to be able to
get the values from that pokey api um
let's see someone is asking
uh by using const on the hook does that
affect the functionality nope
i used const but you can totally use let
you can't create constructor functions
with the arrow functions i guess
you don't need to instead of doing its
constructure function you could just
type whatever you want here
that you just you just don't need a
constructor function
um if you want
to do certain things in your constructor
let me know
there are some consequences for this yes
but also because these are functions and
not
objects anymore the this dot props
doesn't exist anymore it's just
props and whatever you pass into props i
hope that answers
that uh clarification for you okay
so anyway we call set pokemon and it
changes the pokemon state variable
and that's is what's saying hi there we
should have an exclamation point just
because
we like this so we want to populate this
with real data um now
really quick because there's some
questions about class-based and
functional and stuff
um remember that react is declarative
and not imperative
and so if you were to do something like
this like what we just did
with jquery for example um that would be
a more imperative style of programming
um and so this is particularly evident
if you have
a different example so let's just say in
this office
right here where i am um i have two
heaters
i have the wall thermostat back there
i'm a very cold person
not personality wise i mean like
temperature
gosh darn it anyway okay i have the
temperature thing on the wall
right there if you can see i can't move
my hand right
that where i can put in an exact number
of what i want so i can say i want this
to be 72 degrees or whatever
and then i also have a portable heater
down here with a knob that just
increases and decreases the heat
depending on what i want
now react is more like the wall
thermometer with the numbers where i say
i want it to be 72 degrees and the
heater adjusts accordingly it'll be just
like okay well the room is too cold i'm
gonna
heat up if the room is too hot i'm gonna
let it be cool down
meanwhile jquery and many other uh
libraries and stuff are imperative and
are like the portable heater with the
knob
um this example is to say
when you do something with jquery you
need to get the element that you want
parse the parse the element and the
value that you get then
increase that value by a certain amount
and then
say okay now document.getelementid.text
or whatever is equal to this
you you have to do all of that manual
changing to the dom yourself
but with react because it's declarative
you just say i want the count to be this
i want pikachu to be what's on the
screen and it manipulates the dom for
you
you work with the variables that you
want and you say i don't care how you
manipulate the dom
i just want this to be there and it's
done it's kind of like how
uh if you've worked with designers and
they put all the different screens on
like a cork board
that they've printed out and they say
okay this is the error state this is
what this is this is what this is
that's kind of like what react is you
say what you want the ui to look like
given these states and you let it do the
rest with the dom and it takes away a
lot of the work that you would normally
have to do to
manipulate everything i hope that
explains
some of the questions a little bit more
and with functional versus class again
it's instead of having objects that are
all over the screen it's functions that
are called
to the screen and put dom elements on
the page
um and that ends up being even more
declarative and that ends up making it
future safe for concurrent mode and
suspense and a bunch of other stuff
that's coming to react
um do we need to do a controlled input
for the on change
if not why uh that is a good
question and you know what i'll explain
controlled and uncontrolled components
so uh controlled components and
uncontrolled components
are a concept that has existed since the
web has began
since the web has existed but we didn't
actually give it a name
until react uh was a thing so
if you think about just the web in
general how can a user manipulate the
dom without any javascript whatsoever
nothing just just no no javascript the
user is just doing something to the dom
that is with input elements i'm typing
stuff in here and
ignore the the changes that are on the
side here but this actual input box
this is me interacting with the browser
whether you like it or not that's
changing something in the dom
now because the user has control of that
that's called an uncontrolled component
react doesn't control it
uh the user does um but when i do
value right here value turns it into a
controlled component meaning
react is going to capture that value and
control what the user types in
um and i have an example that will take
too long and i want to get to calling an
api
um but i'll write a blog post on this or
something to explain a little bit deeper
that being said uh i also recommend
doing controlled components with this
value equals instead of default value
equals
because that makes it so you have
control over
what the user is typing and you can set
restrictions and stuff
um so anyway that's that is
that is a very very brief overview of
uh controls but the when you do value
equals it's controlled
when you have default it's uncontrolled
there are pros and cons but
you should always do controls just as a
general rule of thumb
okay that being said we want to call an
api so
because we want to call an api we're
going to pull in the hook use effect
the uzi use effect um so
with use effect uh it is named this
because
it is for side effects now with with
functional components as
functional components and and with uh
functional
programming in general there are these
things called side effects and if you
don't know what that is let me do a
quick example let's just say we have
let z equals 10 and then i'll do
let add is equal to
a function in here that returns
two numbers that are being added so i'll
do x and then y
and then x plus y this is just a plain
function
it will always return the same thing but
given certain
inputs if you want to add a side effect
to this function
what i could do is i could do z equals x
plus 10 for example this line right here
is a side effect it doesn't
change the output of the function at all
it's just something that happens
in uh in this component of
whenever or in this function whenever
you use this add function
um and so with react there are
side effects and that's what use effect
is for and so
as a quick example of a side effect
let's just say i have
a use effect in here and i'm going to
put in a function as the first parameter
and then the second parameter is an
array
and i'll do inside of here i'll do
document.title
is equal to say hi
to and then the pokemon
like that and then i want to listen to
that right there so now it says say hi
to pikachu
um you want it to say go pokemon sure
now do it for the people okay i should
have used a template string for this
oh well anyway so now it says go pikachu
right in there
now this is a side effect that
changes every single time i change the
value in this dependency array
so this this this second parameter right
here this array
whenever something in this array changes
it will recall the function in the first
parameter so
because this changes that i could do
ditto
and now it says go ditto in my little
tab up here
and this variable it can be a state
variable but it can
be uh it can be something else this is
going to be covered later but when is
when is use effect run good question use
effect
is run on the initial render so kind of
like component will mount
and then it's also run similarly
uh on every single state change um
and so it's not so much replacing like
component will mount and and something
else
our component did mount it's replacing
a lot of the life cycle methods that are
uh that are in there it's it's uh this
is like angular watch kind of
so what this does is it tells this
function to
stay in sync with this variable in here
and it doesn't have to be a state
variable let's just say i had
let message equal this go pokemon thing
right here
and then i could put message inside of
here and then i'll do
message like this now it does the exact
same thing
if i do that it'll it'll change it um
but it's staying in sync with this and
then let's just say i wanted to
i don't know if a pokemon's name is too
long it's going to get cut off and so
message equals this go pokemon.sub
string
and then i'm just going to say
0 to 5 or something like that
so now it's just saying go pi um and so
now the effect actually isn't being
called because message isn't changing
message is only changing if those first
five characters are changed
and so when i finally do this now it's
actually
it's it's actually calling this use
effect and so again
the effect is called on the initial
render
and whenever something in this value is
changed that being said
you can also make this empty and as a
result of that let me take up this
substring
as a result of that this is only on
initial render and then i can take this
out completely
and then it just runs on every single
state change so
i'm going to actually write that down to
make it easy when you have
some variable in here
that means that the effect
is run on initial
render and when var
changes i'm just going to put var in
there
and then when it's an empty array
then effect is run on initial
render only and then when you have
nothing in there then it's
run on initial render
and every state change
so you can kind of think of it as like
component will receive props
and on component did mount and a bunch
of other things
so you can actually control when use
effect is being called
uh because of this uh dependency array
yes
and and so these are the things that
change it um and let's just say you only
want it to be called
when certain things happen you can just
add if statements inside of here
to make uh certain things happen so i'm
gonna
turn this back into message right here
so that way it
happens whenever that message changes
how do you handle when nested properties
of a state variable change
changes like an array of prop changes
for example
oh so you want it to change whenever
like let's just say you have
something in there you can you can
manipulate it however you want if i
let's just say that message was an array
i can do message sub-zero
and i only want to listen to the first
value of the array or if it was an
object i could do message dot
value or whatever the object was you can
you can listen to very specific things
it doesn't have to be just
one straight variable um let's see
if you call an arrow function inside of
the use effect should i call that
yes so uh that is that is a good
question so
if you have a value inside of here
that is a function you call that and so
let's just say
um let i don't know cake
equals a thing i don't know let's let's
just say it's something that
does something i'm just gonna
console.log pokemon
um and you want to call it inside of
there i'm gonna put
cake like this yes you can do
message and cake like that
and and it will you can have as many
things as you want
inside of this dependency array there
are some people who say that you should
only have one in there
that's kind of up to you and what you're
doing um but yes you can put you can put
functions in there as well
okay let's call an api i've been doing
lots of talking
okay so now that now that we want to
call this api
what we can do inside of this use effect
is is we can just
call a fetch function and again because
it's like componented mount and all
sorts of things it's it's something that
can
happen outside of rendering and it's
something that won't
stop your component from rendering
anything and so what i'm going to do is
i'm actually going to
have this pokemon here i want to also
render an image
and so i'm going to do image and then
set image
and then i'll do a use state of
i'll just have it be null and then
const and then i'll have an error too
just in case the api returns an
error and then i'll do use state
and then i'll also set that to null in
case
something happens okay cool so we have
our input
we have our hello pikachu i'm gonna put
a line break here and then i also want
to
put another line break and then add an
image
and i'll do a conditional down here
where i'll check
if the image exists then i want to
render an image so
this is a kind of a shorthand way of
doing it image and and
image src equals
image and then
i'll do an altis pokemon we're going to
be so accessible
okay cool so now
nothing has changed but we are set up to
actually
call an api um oh ding we just got a
bunch of questions let's see
uh there's a custom hook that handles
objects diffs yes thank you for that
but if we want to do an async call on
the effect and then update the state as
a result of the async call you can do
that
um and that's kind of what we're doing
with this api call that we're about to
do
so i'm going to throw in another use
effect
then inside of this use effect we're
going to start
calling some apis so i'm going to
fetch the pokemon api and i actually
saved a little variable there so that
way i don't have to type all of this out
myself
there cool
okay so we have this in there i don't
have the accent on the e
i should that's fine okay so we're
fetching we're fetching the api
then we're going to do this is just
javascript this isn't even react stuff
we're going to do res and then rez.json
in there
then we want to actually do stuff with
it and i'm going to do
we're going to take that response and
then we're going to
manipulate some state so i'm going to do
set pokemon is
res.name like that
and then i'm going to do set image
image and then inside this pokey api
there's a thing to actually get the
image
somewhere in there sprites
front default okay so it's going to be
res.sprites
dot front default
like that and then we also want to have
a catch
and inside of that catch we're going to
have an error
and that's when we'll set error to
error like that um and i'll
put error in here okay
that should theoretically work we'll
find out oh my gosh look at that it did
ah i love live refreshes
okay uh now we had jigglypuff before
jigglypuff
yeah look at that what
what and right now it's happening on
every state change let's
make sure that it doesn't do it when
like we click a button or something i'll
put
pokemon and i'll put image and i'll put
error so whenever these things change
it's going to recall certain things um
look at that we just called an api you
just do it in use effect
it's beautiful we're set in state in
there it's cute
i'm happy that's great oh
wait that's a great thing i'm going to
say
them all because now we're gonna catch
them all
yes actually em all is better there we
go now we're gonna catch them all
humor okay so this is this is how you
call an api now there are certain
guardrails that i would like to
set up um now let's just say i typed
pikachu
and the request was going super super
slowly
and then because i was getting
frustrated i
then typed ditto super fast and that
request went
fast and we see ditto on the screen but
then when the request
succeeds for pikachu now it's going to
show pikachu even though i typed ditto
it's it's out of date this is this is
something that can happen a lot
and especially if you think of someone
logging in and then someone else
re-logging in and stuff you want to be
able to
make sure your effect is always up to
date uh there's
some good guardrails for doing that and
the simplest one
is just having a variable let's just say
let
is current equal true
and my sister's calling me a tool i had
a webinar okay
so we'll say let is current equals true
and then
inside of here i'll do if is current
and then inside of here i'm going to
do this so if everything is current
then great we're going to set it but we
need to make sure that
is current can be set to false otherwise
it will
always be true whenever a component
dismounts or whenever any of the values
inside of this dependency array
changes return
value of this use effect function is
called
so the function here is called a cleanup
function
and in this cleanup function this is
where let's just say you have certain
things set
and you want to for example turn off an
event listener
that you have this is where you would do
it so this is kind of component will
unmount
in react class base component words
and so inside of here what i can do is
is current
is now false and so
whenever pokemon whenever this pokemon
function
is unmounted let's just say we'd
navigate to a different page or
something
or whenever the state changes um
pokemon image or error it will call this
function right here
this uh this arrow function is current
as false
and stuff and so as a result the fetch
that you made
in that first call of views effect um
will then be cancelled or rather the
fetch can't be canceled sadly because
javascript is broken but uh the state
changes won't actually happen and so
it'll check
is this a current iteration of this of
this component
then great we we can set this otherwise
this is bad um yes the state changes
every time we press a letter
um i'm not going to worry about
debouncing right now and being just like
ah make sure that you have typed a full
pokemon name and validate it
but yes you could also put uh guardrails
like
if the event.target.value is greater
than a certain length
then actually call the state change and
do stuff um i'm not going to do that now
but
you can and and that is allowed um
and yeah you don't need axios or
anything you can just
you can just do this variable and what
you can do is you can actually make
custom hooks out of this as well and so
uh
a custom hook uh if you ever hear that
as a buzzword
all it is is a function that wraps a
hook and so for example right now we
have this use effect right here with the
document title
if i did function function
use document
title like this
i can just plop this whole thing in
there i'm taking it out
putting it right in there and then i'll
pass in message
and now i can do use
document title with
message passed in voila it works the
exact same way
but now you can make whole separate
files that have your own custom hooks
outside of your components and so your
functional components can stay
really clean because your hooks can live
elsewhere i can even put
these state variables i can put this in
a separate
uh hook and be just like use pokemon
state
and then when i do use pokemon state it
has all of these values that are passed
in
so your actual components itself that
render
all of these divs and actual html and
everything
they can get really really clean really
really fast when you do this and i can
do the same thing with
this i could turn this into use pokemon
and just make sure that it returns the
right values
that uh that need to be passed in here
and so it it
it's it's pretty powerful that way um
let's see so use effect is some kind of
component did mount component will help
mount
in class components yeah it can it can
do
pretty much everything except for error
boundaries which again
that is gonna be in react soon tm
um can you use async weight instead of
promises yes uh i just
this is easier to write but yes you can
um
you can't do it out here like i can't do
async right here or
you know a weight whatever um you would
have to do it in a function
and then do like async function whatever
whatever
and then do it inside of there the the
function that is passed in
to this use effect right here it has to
be immediately invokable
if you put a cnk weight in front of it
that turns it into a promise type
and not a function in react will yell at
you
um but you can have as many use effects
calls as you want in a component you can
have as many use states as you want in a
component
you can have as many hooks as you want
inside a single component
um let's see we end at 5 30. so we still
have
some time um what if we talk about
reducers shall we
reducers are really fun um and uh
some people might be just like wow her
version of fun sucks
but uh trust me reducers are very cool
and i'm going to explain why
so again we have all of these beautiful
pieces of state and instead of having
these
separate pieces of state let's just say
that we want to have
a reducer for it um we can
we are allowed it's great so in order
in order to do that let's see can we use
an is current on an if statement outside
of use effect
yeah i mean the the scope of use current
is inside of here but you could put it
somewhere and do something yeah it's
just javascript
um is there a way we can determine which
prop
updated using use effect uh yes and
it's escaping me now but honestly just
do if statements
and that that's a thing i know some
people have made custom hooks for that
specific case
um but off the top of my head i can't
think of how to implement it because my
brain is tired
and because i'm thinking about reducers
now uh can i access
the ditto in the first slow request oh
and that in that mistake
thing that i talked about um yeah you
can capture it and then store it in a
ref or something
um and i don't want to jump around
too much so i'm going to talk about
reducers but know that a ref is a
variable
that's you can it doesn't
uh it doesn't trigger a state change
when it changes and so you could do
like let poop equals use ref and then
set values inside of poop um should not
use that as a variable name i'm a
professional
but when you do that it can be something
that persists across
time and space and you can have refs
that are specific to
uh old api calls or something like that
um or you could log it there there's a
lot of options there and you can do
stuff
outside of this is current and and just
do things and log that sort of thing
okay so again
reducers reducers are cool um if you
have not uh let's see is it all right to
ask a rather off off-topic question
or are we only allowed to ask react
questions in here i mean
i don't know what you want to ask but
you can go for it and i can i can try
um but i'm going to be sticking to
generally reducer and react questions
now
but i mean hey it might be useful to
answer other questions
um could we be brief about use callback
and use memo sure i'll do that at the
end
i'm not going to be talking about
mechanical keyboards because
you'll never hear about react again okay
so anyway gonna talk about reducers now
uh
what are reducers reducers are something
that actually exists in math and stuff
and it's not necessarily
uh it's not necessarily a react concept
but it was made particularly popular in
react
um because of redux and if you don't
know redux
fun fact you don't have to learn it
anymore thanks to reducers
um so there are there are some great
hooks that
i could talk about these for literally
hours i've taught two full day workshops
on
this stuff but redux you don't need to
learn anymore
um because of the context api and the
use reducer hook
i'm not going to get into context today
long story short it lets you share state
that being said let's talk about
reducers let's just say i have an array
and it's an array of numbers i'm going
to say two three four
five in there um and i want to use my
add function from before
i'm gonna take out the side effect but
i'm just gonna scoot this down here
kill these off and take out this whole z
thing so let's just say you have an
array and you have add that returns x
plus y
and then you have let sum is equal to
array.reduce and then add
and then zero do you know what's going
to happen
in case you don't i'm going to do
console.log
of the sum right in here
15 aha it added everything together but
how
i will show you what it does on the
first iteration it does zero plus one
and so it takes this zero right here and
then the one
adds them together then on the next
iteration
it does one plus two it's not doing
these one plus two
it's doing the sum of the previous
invocation and then adding it to two
and then on the next one you can guess
it it's three plus three
so it takes the sum of the previous
indication then adds it to the next one
then the next one is going to be 6 plus
4
takes this 3 plus 3 the sum of that and
then adds it to 4
and then you guessed it it does 10 plus
5
and then it takes that previous value
adds it to the last value of the array
voila you get 15.
so this is how reducers work in general
just in terms of math
what's cool about it though is if you
think of this as some kind of
state changing function and then this
zero right here as the initial
value the initial state for your
component and so you could have some
kind of reducer function
function reducer that takes in
a state and an action and then
someone said does the arrow function
always need to return one value only i
mean
most functions return one thing but you
can
you can put stuff in here console.log
hi there you go anyway
um so anyway we have a
reducer state in action and and what it
really does is it returns
the state and then whatever action you
applied to it so let's
let's do a more detailed example than
this array thing
let's just say you have a const initial
state of
count is zero we're going to come back
to our counter component
and then i'll do cake as false
because we don't have cake you know you
know what cake is true i want cake
and then i'll say we have a user is some
empty object or something like that uh
the return should be a primitive i think
that's a question
oh yeah i mean you'll see it doesn't
have to be a primitive
in things you'll see you'll see anyway
um so we have count to zero cake is true
user is an object um we want to apply
actions
to uh to this initial state and so i'm
going to have
an actions array and then in this
actions array
we're going to say let's just say we
have an action
type is add and whenever we have the
action type
of add we want to increase it by two
and then and then we'll do the exact
same thing but we'll have minus
and we'll say when we have an action of
type
minus then it'll decrease it
by four or something
and then we can have some other thing
where we have like
type and then eat
cake and we don't have to do anything
just if we eat cake then
cake will be false how about that so we
have these actions we want to apply
these actions
and so inside of our reducer function we
need to take those actions into account
and return a new state so
what we can do is i can have an if
statement here and if
action.type is equal to add
then we want to return a new state
inside
of here and we want to make our new
state
equal uh the existing state object but
with certain values changed so i'll do
count is equal to the current state dot
count
and then plus that action dot by
which is what we're getting from up here
and i'll do the
exact same thing but with uh
else it's going to do else if
action dot type is equal to
minus i need to do more than just an
equal how about that
okay life is hard okay
minus then
we'll return this whole thing i'm going
to copy it
but it's going to be minus action dot by
and then else i'll just
we'll say that these are the only
actions that we have available right now
i'll say else will return
the current state but then
cake is false the cake is a lie
okay cool this is our reducer function
now
so if we want to make it real i'll just
do a console.log
actions.reduce our reducer function
and then our initial state
so now look at that we have count
negative two so we
made it from zero to positive two to
minus four
and then cake is false so we have
applied all of these state changes
to it isn't that great oh my gosh how
about that
um i'm scrolling back and it's mostly
just cake as a lie joke so that's
perfect that's all i need to hear
so this is this is how reducers work
it's great
um and this is this is how the use
reducer hook
works as well this is this is how redux
works under the hood
um and the thing is
we won't always know what these actions
are
these these actions are something where
you don't always know that a user is
going to get on my website then they
will
click this button then they will open
this then they will do that you don't
know that
and so there's a function called a
dispatch function that populates this
actions array
and then applies the state changes based
on
based on that okay um
so okay i see so many people copying and
pasting
you you're welcome and i hope that's on
ted
thanks anyway so uh now that we've done
this
um what i'm going to do is i'm going to
convert
these three use states to use reducer
and i think that'll
make us uh get right on time for the end
and i can answer some last minute
questions then
so if i want to convert all of these to
user reducer
what i'll do is a user reducer returns a
tuple just like you state
but the values in there are the current
state and dispatch
so const state and dispatch
is equal to use reducer oh and i also
need to import it at the top
use reducer like that
okay so uh where did i go here we go
use reducer now you can use
user reducer and use state all in the
same component if you want to that's
totally allowed
fun fact if you actually look at the
code that implements use state
use state is implemented with use
reducer so they actually work together
very very well now uh with use reducer
what it takes in uh instead of just one
initial value because this is a whole
state and this is a whole dispatch thing
that will change that
whole state object it takes in a reducer
function
and then it also takes in an initial
state object
and so i'm going to make this initial
state object to have
pokemon image and error in there and so
we have pokemon the initial value of
that is pikachu
and then we have sorry about the pop-up
we have image the initial value
is null we have error and the initial
value
is null and there you go we have those
values
if we want to use them this this is
where things are going to break
initially but i promise they'll come
back and it'll work
if we want to use them we do let and
then
pokemon image and then error
equal state because we're getting this
state value from use reducer
okay so that's how we get that but we're
still calling this set pokemon set image
set error
we have all these functions that we're
calling but we're not actually using
them
which is a problem so what i'm going to
do is i'm going to
implement this reducer function i'm
going to turn this just into an error
function here
and now inside of this reducer function
what we
get is a state and an action
and we want to dispatch actions to this
state
and action right here and we're going to
return
new states and stuff inside of there so
what i can do
is i can say with this set pokemon set
image
i can actually group state changes
together so instead of doing
two different dispatches right here i
can do dispatch
and then i'll say type is
load pokemon load pokemon
and then when we do that we'll pass in
the response and so i'll do
a name is res.name
and then image is res.image
like that and then oh
i saved it but it's yelling at me for
calling these functions
cool we've done this uh res.name res dot
image thing
and now uh we need to take care of this
load pokemon
uh thing right in here so let's see
uh where's my function there it is so
what i can do
is i'll make a switch statement instead
of instead of an if statement
we're going to switch on action.type
and then inside of action.type we're
going to have
a case for load pokemon load
pokemon um and then with these you can
make enums and put them in separate
files and stuff but
this is just an example so you get it
i'm going to return
the current state but certain things
will be changed
and it's going to be the action.name and
the action.image
so pokemon
is now equal to action dot name
and then let's see yeah pokemon is
action.name and then image is res.image
so
image is action.image like that
i'm still getting errors on the side and
that's because i still have to get rid
of some of those
okay so that's we've just replaced a
couple of those
in there um and now we can do another
one we're going to catch them all
um it's not going to be as clever
sounding now we're going to dispatch and
then we're going to have a type
of error and then we have type error
we'll just pass in error right here and
now
up here i'll do a case for error
do case error and then
inside of there we'll return
state and then error is
action dot error like that uh we should
also have a default case and i'll just
say
default is i'll just return state
so it doesn't actually do anything okay
we still have a couple that i need to
get rid of
let's see we're commenting this out that
one's gone
now we have to do it down here we're
just gonna i'll just do a dispatch
set pokemon type pokemon name i don't
know
uh type
cassidy because i feel like it and then
i'm going to
do pokemon is
event.target.value and then whenever we
have the type of cassidy we're going to
do this pokemon this is starting to get
a little bit hacky looking isn't it
but that is okay um do i need error
m all i probably do did i not pass it in
oh
you're right i'm all thank you for
fixing that that was right okay uh
case for cassidy bail me out
okay case for cassidy in there
we're going to do return
and then in there state and then
what did i call it pokemon i think i did
yeah
we'll just do pokemon is action.pokemon
and uh pokemon okay
now i need to get rid of the set pokemon
in there and i
think that's it please oh thank goodness
yay okay so now this is the initial
state what if i were to do ditto
does it do it hmm why am i not getting
my image
something is up uh res.sprite's not
res.image thank you very much
uh i needed to do this whole res sprites
front default
good call thank you for uh letting me
know so i didn't
think about it there it is all right and
now if i
were to do what's a more obscure one i
don't know
c dot is that in there yeah it is cool
so this is how you convert to reducers
this is kind of long and it can get very
long but again because of custom hooks
you can make a whole like pokemon
reducer thing and put it
elsewhere in your code you can you can
export things really nice and easily
and make your state live elsewhere but
this is generally how
you use reducers and what's cool about
it is you can
not just do load pokemon error set
certain pokemon things and use it as a
regular
state thing but you can create full-on
state machines
and call functions inside of here where
let's just say whenever i do load
pokemon i also want
to call some function inside of here
and so it doesn't just do a state change
but it might trigger a side effect it
might do
something else reducers are very
powerful
and you can really hack them to do a lot
of really cool things
how much state would you have before you
would reach for reducers
i personally try to
use these state as much as i can but
once i get past like four or five use
states in a component
that's when uh that's when i switched to
use reducers
um this feels too ad hoc how would uh
how would it show up in the wild just
export the reducer away
yeah i mean this again is kind of a
hacky
one there are a lot cleaner examples out
there in the world
um but this is you can export the
reducer away
yeah the effects cleanup was it was
supposed to avoid all the network calls
so it did it's it's hard to explain but
basically it just didn't do the
debouncing it's still called
the things i just didn't type fast
enough it technically worked but
my internet connection is fast but yes
andre you're you're right but
my internet is fast if i were to like
thwart it in some way and then and then
do it it would
it would clean it up a little bit faster
but it just made the api calls because i
didn't type fast enough again this isn't
a bouncing lecture
but that's a thing but yeah if i copied
and pasted let's just say i
oh i don't know if i can even copy and
paste that fast
i'm gonna copy and paste ditto really
fast
and then undo okay ready
oh wow that was really fast look at that
that's amazing
the internet is cool um but anyway
technically that's that's what it should
do uh more than number of you states i
reach for use reducer when you have one
action that starts changing multiple
states that's also true
notice how we were able to group states
together um where was it
right here where i did load pokemon it
it lets you kind of use more product
focused language
where instead of doing oh i'm setting
the state of pokemon then i'm setting
the state of image
we can know ah this group of states
change state
when i load pokemon um and this is only
two but imagine that you're setting
state of like
three or four different variables at
once when an api call is set or
something changes size or something like
that this allows you to
know that it happens when pokemon is
loaded or when
an error is called or when instead of
cassidy i did
user input or something and change this
to
user input like that
um and so yeah when you group state
changes
that's really useful or yeah different
different amounts of form data
there is a thing that is incredibly rare
and the react team is pretty good at
grouping it
but let's just say you still had these
and then something happened
in between these two state changes
that's called tearing
it typically doesn't happen again
they're very good at grouping state
changes but
using reducers destroys that problem of
tearing
where something might happen in between
these two state changes
again that's very rare and you don't
really have to worry about it but
in in this world crazy things can happen
um i'm currently working with monorepos
what do you think about the integration
between react and angular
um i personally haven't done that before
so
i know it's possible but i cannot speak
to it
and good luck um will i be posting the
code sure i can make a gist of it and
i'll post it in the chat before we end
um one last thing someone asked about
use memo and use callback
um the main use effect is making a
request to the api
should we be taking care of that i'm not
sure what you mean by taking care of
that
but yes it is doing that yes i can clean
this up
a lot but i'm not going to right now
anyway
um cleanup functions hey that's kind of
a pun
uh use memo and use callback
those two those two hooks are ones that
you will hear a lot
what they are are ways to
optimize your performance and so let's
just say
i have some function i'm going to do
let some function let's just say i have
some function that does a very expensive
calculation
like it does some calculation of things
and it returns
i'm just gonna return cake again
man i really want cake but anyway let's
just say you have some function that
returns cake
and so every single time pokemon is run
and we call
some function in return like let's just
say we we
call some function in here whenever i
click a button i don't know something
like that
or whenever the the function renders
this let's just say we have something
expensive in here
that takes a lot of code to compile to
builds to
to run um like calculating certain
amount of dates and the differences
between them i don't know
um this can slow down your code
um and and it's usually our fault and
not react's faults because it's
something that's slow
what you can do is find use memo
use memo and
we can we can make it so that let's just
say it does cake
plus pokemon just for this example
um this doesn't make sense but you'll
see we have this expansion
expensive function what i can do is i
can do use memo
around this function right here where
the first parameter is the function then
the second parameter is
a dependency array just like use effect
um
what it will do then cannot access okay
don't yell at me
uh oh that's because i did it up here
i've got to do it down here
because of where pokemon was declared
okay don't yell at me we're good okay
so what this does is it will make this
expensive calculation
and then you can use some function you
can use the value inside of some
function it's technically some value
because this isn't returning a function
anyway um
we get this value this expensive
calculation react will save that value
it's memoized it sounds like memorized
but like a baby said it
it's memoized and then it won't
recalculate and do this expensive
calculation unless this value of pokemon
changes
um and so this is a way to kind of
reduce the
number of things that happen in your
code um
use callback is the exact same thing
where let's just say
it this actually does return a function
and
and it does this or something that's
when this happens it ends up honestly
it looks silly because this is kind of
what ends up happening
right here and it looks dumb all use
callback
is is
it it wraps it wraps it so that way you
can only have one of those
double uh arrow functions instead of two
um that's that's it so that's that's all
use callback is
um but that that's that's what use memo
and use callback is for
and so it's a way to reduce expensive uh
calculations that you might have
um that's kind of a fast explanation of
it but that's that's really all they are
um and you'll you'll see it a lot for uh
if you
memoize some large value that you might
pull from a use effect
and do that sort of thing um what's the
difference between use memo and use
effect with only one
dependency use memo return something use
effect does not
the only thing that use effect returns
is the cleanup function
but use memo is something that returns a
value that will be shared and saved
are there any other questions before i
start saving this and then start
wrapping up
this is a very large file i'm going to
just github.com i'm going to save it and
i'll put it in the chat so that way you
can
access it and i'll do a wise line
webinar on hooks and put it in there
let's see i have a question about you
state what is the difference between set
count previous common previous complex
one
they do basically work in the same way
you can totally do that alan
ah for that that one okay i'm copying
and pasting and i'm calling this
wiseline.js create a public gist
and then i will share it
cool and then i am putting it in the
chat and you can look at it
and i'll update it if i have to type
anything else but are there any other
questions
you all have been great uh asking a
bunch of things
uh let's see could you i again explain
the difference between controlled and
uncontrolled components
long story short controlled components
are something that react
uh controls the state of and
uncontrolled components are things that
react does not control the state of it's
just a user typing things in
so you assign both the on change and the
value on the element
and uncontrolled is just the value on
the element
um what about another hooks you can
import whatever hooks you want
um like let's just say i made this
export function use document title i
could have a whole file called hooks.js
or a separate folder of all my different
hooks
like that and then i could make my hooks
live somewhere else and
import them in you're very welcome
everyone
all right well thank you so much for
having me this was great
um if you want to contact me i put my
github there because you got the gist
but feel free to tweet me
twitter.com cassadoo i just put that in
the chat
you can ask me questions anytime and
i hope this was useful one question how
do you eat cake if it's a lie
i don't even know my favorite switch is
silence
i was typing on this keyboard with some
silence
this keyboard right next to me is also
silence i like those ones
a bunch do i have some kind of course in
udemy or
pluralsight uh i
have a udemy one but it's using an old
version of react i'm working on a new
one that will be on scrimba and i'll
release that soon
that's about it okay i'll let the
organizers take it away